there's a whole another squad behind all
of the action so this scene is like
widely known as one of the worst action
scenes of all time break down one of
your favorite fight scenes for us
this is my favorite shot that i got to
do right here
thanks to disco for sponsoring today's
episode if you guys want to find out how
to get three months free of the best
cloud storage interface money can buy
stick around hey everybody welcome to a
very special episode we're not talking
about just stunts we're not talking
about just vfx today we're talking about
action design and we're talking about it
with none other than chris cohen who is
an action designer it's basically his
job to take the stuntman and the
choreography and make it look good on
camera so that requires a lot of
intuition for camera motion cutting
points angles there's a whole other
squad behind all of the action so if you
love action and you want to get a deeper
understanding of it well this is the
episode for you should we jump right in
with kingsman let's do it
there's two units on the film there's
the main unit and they typically handle
all of the dialogue all the acting and
then there's the second unit which does
all the action this was my first job
ever getting to hold the camera it was
nerve-wracking for me because i was
working with the main unit director
matthew vaughn to have everyone there
and they're like chris go i was like
whoa like
it was a tight fit yeah how do you film
in a car like this the sfx department
tore this cab apart they shot with a
re-alexa mini it was stripped down
completely because i was like yeah we
can't do this stuff with a 50-pound
camera
right here to start the shot they have
they took out the roof and you're on a
crane the crane will boom down follow
the hand right here hold hold hold
that's ed and then right there that's my
buddy andy
andy was the stunt double and i can tell
that that's him because he always makes
that face
this is my favorite shot that i got to
do right here but he catches it with his
toe yeah
and taryn killed it on that he did it
himself yeah he did that was him wow
good for him is that all one shot
without any cuts that was all one shot
yeah but they had like this mechanical
arm underneath that swung and and spun
at the same time brad had the detail
that he wanted to see the toe to the
second toe and see like the full body
extension not only that the pressure was
on to continue the shot from the face
look up find the button then back down
to the face and then pull back and see
full body when you're doing a lot of big
action like this you really want to keep
some of the stuff especially your your
in and out points either central or if
like say if it's frame left it's better
to pick up the next shot starting with
the central point being framed left that
way people don't have to try to find it
you know miss key moments you can see
like for the uh the old ball punch here
just going straight but as we cut in you
know the fist is still still centered
and that's such a high level of craft
and i think that goes completely over a
lot of filmmakers heads when they're
doing action
[Music]
how do you do that taren was on a wire
and they had him yanked through
and
and i had to physically get back because
that wire he was coming out no matter
what there's something about your work
that i think that's actually it's been a
big influence on me always in your
fights you know the actors choreographed
to throw a right hook the other actor's
choreographed to block it with his right
hand and then cameras choreographed
angle twist pop out punch zoom right so
you have your own fight scene that
you're doing with the camera while the
other guys aren't doing their fight on
top of it yeah we we joke and call it
kam chi kam g
you have to have the you know the
presence of mind to remember the choreo
and remember the beats um and once you
can you can just start dancing with them
and telling cool stories within their
movement i love that this fight scene
shows little mini stories always little
problems that they need to be solved and
they're solved in clever ways and it
takes you to the next little problem
that needs to be solved in a clever way
as long as you have the moments in in
the scene within the scene and you just
have you know choreo in between to take
you to the next moment each beat is
so much more emphasized
[Music]
the diner sequence so you worked on this
as well right yes this was a lot of
running around especially when it starts
the the long one-shot sequence
definitely inspired by the first movie
[Music]
oh man that is such a cool shot
way over these blends these matches
and they show it burger time all right
tell us a little bit about this insanity
that is the same see
that right there he's not holding
anything he's just holding the rope all
the way up into his right hand and
that's fully animated afterwards the
light trail it's like that's a good
touch on it too and all the ground is
all padded they'll come in and they'll
put in foam mats to let them you know to
hit
colin firth is i think a real kingsman
on and off camera
like just a gentleman he's the coolest
dude ever i'm surprised at how spry he
is considering how old he is
he gets it done
this this shot i'm holding a rig and the
camera is inside of this sort of cage
and someone is on a remote control who's
able to control the roll wow so i'm just
tracking and someone is rolling with
[Music]
you start behind the counter right and
now you're on the other side of the
counter
our department was able to remove
certain sections of the counter
and then vfx department put them back in
these camera moves you're flying around
all over the place how are you doing
that while keeping it somewhat smooth
really that's just all handheld and
that's that's all handheld yeah because
it looks like it's on a city cam oh
excellent
that just goes from years of experience
not having any equipment
[Applause]
this was actually shot all on green they
rebuilt the entire background in the air
they they got a face uh element of of
pedro oh that's a stunt man yeah that's
all three are stunt man really those are
all face replacements yeah wow
i can tell you're proud of this scene
because when you're watching it like
you're you're in it reacting to it and
that's a really good sign what was cool
about working for matthew vaughn is that
he told the action team he was like
don't hold back think outside of the box
completely just go crazy if it's too
crazy we'll tone it back but don't think
you have to work within these sort of
guidelines every product of uh genius is
the product of enthusiasm so ooh i like
that it's a good saying found it on a
fortune cookie
please consider subscribing to the
channel if you have not already we're
banging out good stuff all the time you
might not even know it but on the days
that aren't the weekends we also put out
videos on this channel and they're good
[Music]
what go out the back i have another car
oh god i remember this infuriated me
okay
so this scene is like widely known as
one of the worst action scenes of all
time it's been ridiculed it started the
whole meme of like the shaky cam and
shaky cam has its place it does it does
but there's shots in this fight scene
where the camera's clearly on a dude's
shoulder and he's on a wide angle but
it's
like whoa right are you okay
you're not following his attacks it's
like the camera seems to almost move in
the opposite direction of what you're
trying to watch
yeah there's a random shot of dude's
legs there in the middle let's have him
knee the guy and show their faces
how would you shoot this to keep a
little bit of the style but make it a
better like read more readable fight
scene with more emotions and more impact
follow the attacks one of the most
important things is seeing what's
actually happening like if someone's
going for a kick
don't show the shoulders
[Laughter]
way less cuts let it breathe let your
choreo breathe let the audience watch
you know what they're doing you know if
they're doing like three cuts for one
punch you're like one two three yeah
that's way too many is that a cg matt
damon
[Laughter]
you turn the stove on you jam a magazine
in the toaster you set it to extra
crispy
and so right when your magazine's done
and ready to eat the house will explode
so i have a quick request for you guys
it's easy to find good action scenes
there's a lot of them out there but it's
really hard to find bad action scenes
that are worth talking about and
breaking down so if you guys have a
action scene that you think is just
awful that would be great we would love
to do that in some future videos so
please leave a comment
so when i was watching solo this was the
scene that definitely stood out to me
and this is i i didn't even know you had
worked on this one either too it's just
like like oh this is good
there's some cool concepts going into
this so this
was really cool to shoot also very
nerve-wracking the train's actually on a
rig to do these full tilts really we are
up in the air about 30-40 feet i'm not a
stunt guy
i'm not a heights guy
to have me up there shooting i was like
my favorite shot that i got to do this
little stitch we go from andy lister
amazing stunt man again to uh woody
harrelson and the stitch happens right
there
what's the trick for getting a good
stitch just making sure that all parties
repeat their motion the best way you do
it a few times enough times you're going
to get you'll get something that works
[Music]
what was fun about this shoot too is
that they had this system called invis
this shot right here for instance
through the camera i could see
these storm riders
riding around i could see the mountains
i could see yeah certain you know bins
in the track i could see the the rest of
the train it helped me frame what was
going on and the actors are doing their
best by cues to look they're they're
just looking at blue
they're like we have no idea what's
going on
they have realistic masks for the stunt
performer to wear this movie and
kingsman both had them that is a mask
wow on top of our stunt performer that's
crazy some arya stark stuff going on 100
[Laughter]
oh man
standing next to chewie on set
is surreal you're like because you keep
like he'll be standing there and you
just sort of keep like that's
oh it's chewy
that's crazy i know that a lot of your
inspiration is anime 100
anime is insane the action design that's
used in in anime has like changed me
completely anime is hand-drawn you know
every frame is labored over and you've
brought that over to the world of
live-action film i love it break down
one of your favorite fight scenes for us
okay if you guys are familiar with uh
naruto's she put in don't don't roast me
for
pronunciation
the kakashi obito fight oh and it's all
silent with just the sound effects and
they do this like really cool not back
to when they were kids
i i love how an animated action moments
hang and pause differently than they
would in reality yeah there's like a
natural speed ramping to anime yeah
like that you know like the blood
suddenly
see how see how it like pauses for a
little bit and then boom like you really
build up to the
that's sick
and i love these shots like come on yeah
i've been waiting to try to do some
stuff like that what i draw from is how
they do moments you do you go choreo
papa pop to go into like something like
this to draw their eye to something
happening and people are like you know
what's that the next shot is typically a
wide to reveal what that is i feel like
that's what keeps people interested when
they don't know what's coming next and
anime is really really good with that
you're taking your hand at doing some
anime i have this is i think the closest
we come to seeing it happen right here
[Music]
the most ripped high school student
like oh my god you're getting the beats
you're getting the rhythms of like
actual anime i appreciate it this was
100
last minute he comes over who you guys
have met in the previous stuntman reacts
and we stumble upon this idea to just
try a version of my hero if ua high
school was based in los angeles
[Music]
wait how do you get him to lift off the
ground like that you're not using wires
no he's just they are all just going
forward and being you know such anime
fans themselves they sort of understand
the body language i have never seen
somebody get the grass angle from anime
before is it just like a little camera
on a gimbal yeah it's a tiny pocket
camera wow it looks great
[Music]
so that shot is yeah okay so how did you
do this shot because it looks
super cool basically i'm just trying to
repeat the same motion wait wait wait
everything else makes sense because it's
like oh this is maybe a match cut or a
jump cut but this one looks kind of
perfect except for if you find it there
i didn't direct nate properly you see
that but because your eye is following
the backpack and what gee is doing
that's my sort of whip pan stitch right
there
i haven't had one comment call me out
yet
[Music]
jay's character i was like we just have
to make it look as seamless as possible
dude you're just pulling the zack king
here we just do it until you nail it
yeah it's yeah it just comes down to
having really good choreography that
like has enough motion to keep your eye
distracted
[Music]
you almost did your infinite
rolling shots
the fact that we have this tool that is
the internet now i mean
it's allowed all of us to wedge
ourselves into this industry without
asking it's like no we're
we're here we're gonna make stuff the
end of the day you're always making your
content for an audience and now we get
to just make it directly for you there's
not really anybody in between that gets
to decide what happens it's just we make
it you watch it and that's that the
internet changed everything man we got
to do an anime video together
100
it would be it would be awesome
uala part 3 is out right now there's
something on the screen you can click it
and you can go watch it right now and
have your mind blown his youtube channel
is riven x3i you can also follow them on
instagram it's the same thing
chris i hope you continue to make
awesome work thank you guys so much for
having me it's our pleasure yeah you
betting is awesome
oh
hey it's your old pal brandi o'daniel
here you see jake sent me up because he
said mr nico played some music for you a
couple weeks ago so if you'd obliged me
i'd like to play a little tune here on
my mandolin but first i gotta tell you
about today's sponsor disco you see
disco is basically like virtual heaven
disco allows you to work on all of your
files that you have in cloud storage
seamlessly from your home computer and
then it puts them right back there where
it found them back on the cloud so
whether or not you use google drive or
dropbox or any of these other popular
platforms doesn't matter you don't have
to be constantly signing in just to
access your files it's real simple disco
links your cloud drives as if they were
actual hard drives on your computer
meaning you can easily move files back
and forth all without taking up space
the most important thing that it does
for us around here is it allows us to
work much more efficiently which allows
me to focus more on my music
and just like a g chord it makes me all
happy inside so if you're like us and
you're working with multiple clients
transferring large data sets back and
forth across these different platforms
boy i gotta tell you you get yourself
disco and you'll be hotter than a four
4v8 so if you want to sign up for disco
just go to patreon dot me
corridor and all the details will be
right there for you also if you're
interested in finding out how to get
three months free click the link in the
description below now on to that song i
was telling y'all about
when you get the blues
don't hurry
just get disco and go on get your files
come right back home with a country mile
and you'll be right here
sitting with your
videos and photos and everything
creative that you do